did you enjoy playing such a strong
heroic female character and if so why I
did I but I also enjoyed that she's not
just those things they is kind of a
simple young woman and she just gets
swept onto this incredible journey so to
play a role that's so nuanced and an
incredibly emotional role was thrilling
because it wasn't it wasn't why I
expected I don't think it is going to be
what people expect and that is
incredibly exciting what do you want
girls to take away from the movie I
would love firstly girls to enjoy as a
whole and the secondly from Ray I hope
they feel uplifted and hopeful and see
themselves in her somewhere and feel
joyful what does it feel to be a star in
a movie franchise that has such a
following do you feel a responsibility
to the fans
I think JJ and Kathy probably feel more
of a responsibility than I do because
I'm just saying the words trying to do a
good job but of course we all hope that
everyone's going to enjoy it but there
are a lot of people to please there are
the old fans who have certain
expectations and there are new fans who
hopefully will come on board who perhaps
haven't been so immersed in Star Wars
before and I think with JJ at the helm
and Larry writing the story they have
combining the older than you so
brilliantly I think it will appeal to
many many people yes first there was
Princess Leia and now there's ray how
are they similar and how are they
different
the main difference is that ray o Leia
comes from privilege and Ray doesn't
Leia is obviously born into something
she there's a certain level of hierarchy
and everything and Ray is definitely at
the bottom of the pile she really is
just working to live every day she's not
in charge of anything she doesn't really
have anyone to have relationships with
being in brothers or husbands or a
squadron I guess underneath her
similarity is that they're both women
trying to make a work trying to make
their way in the world and they're both
pretty kick-ass
talk about the importance of music in
this tone well we went to go and see the
scoring with John Williams a few months
ago which was unbelievable because you
you watch what's going on and the scenes
are already incredible and then adding
the music to it it's like another thing
it's like seeing a whole other thing and
I had to leave at one point because I
was pretty emotional and so to see that
all come together
I can't wait it's absolutely stunning
amazing you jumped right into the movie
by filming in the deserts of Abu Dhabi
what did you learn about yourself from
that experience Abu Dhabi for me was a
real baptism of fire I was incredibly
nervous like I really was and looking
back it's amazing because Ray's journey
begins in Jaco and that's where we began
filming and I learnt that even though I
am terrified a lot of the time and even
though I don't know what I'm doing with
the right support and the right people
around you you can you can break through
boundaries you might put on yourself
restrictions you might think that you
have and and do some really cool stuff
what was it like for you as a young
actress to play opposite Harrison Ford
Carrie Fisher and Mark Hamill Harrison
Carrie and Mark are all brilliant people
and they're all incredibly different
because they're different people united
by this incredible thing and they were
all so excited to come back and that is
incredibly joyful for us because coming
into this you think who knows better
than they do about what story should be
told and how excited we should all feel
so they really set a precedent they're
all incredibly kind and warm and funny
and wonderful to work with and it never
really felt like we were the newbies it
just felt like a group trying to do the
best film trying to make the best film
possible right if you had to describe
your experience making the sum in one
word what would it be and why
one word a rollercoaster because my Star
Wars journey has now spanned over two
years I started auditioning over two
years ago and so obviously within two
years not only with this film but many
many things have happened so I've hit
every emotion possible so that is why I
would say roller coaster last question
you've never worked on such a large
scale film before
tell us what you thought of the sets and
the creatures and did it inform your
acting in any way I think for me it
didn't feel like working on a huge film
the way people talk about huge films it
didn't feel like that it felt intimate
and I'm kind of small and then you
realize obviously this fan of how many
people it takes to make such a such a
film but and the creatures are in same
insane and of course they inform because
they said that they set the tone in the
desert in particular where we started
the creatures were they're already
setting this tone of Star Wars
there's humanoids and creatures all
working alien little kind of working
side by side
I can't move what the other part the
question was did he inform your acting
in any way yeah it really helped JJ and
Cathy wanted to really base everything
of practical effects and having
creatures really there there was nothing
to imagine they were just right there in
front of you so it was incredibly
helpful yeah in what ways did being in
Star Wars The Force awakens meet your
expectations as an actor under the fan I
knew that as an actor of having JJ
Abrams as director was gonna expose me
to quality notes for character and he
was I was gonna be led by a director who
had a vision but also had space for me
to do my thing and create and fin which
met my expectations and as a fan I knew
that was going to be able to have access
to Harrison 24/7 for him to sign my
merchandise so that was fun
how does your character fin allow new
fans to connect to Star Wars through his
eyes fin fin is is interesting because I
feel like he comes from
perspective of the audience so audience
members will be able to relate in
certain scenes where JJ would would
would have things go a certain way I'd
always go let's have fin just not know
about what's going on right here because
you know that would be an interesting
take and I feel like for people who have
never watched Star Wars before when
they're like this wait what's going on
it'll be great because feeling will be
like that too so they'll be able to
follow him through that story how
impressive were the practical sets how
important today were they to you as an
actor the practical sets were definitely
impressive the Millennium Falcon was
thought it was the one that stood out to
me because it was it was full-sized it
was there's steam coming out of the of
the pits and and being inside a tissue
in the scenes was definitely quite it
was quite something talk about the
importance of music in this film I went
to we went to Fox the Fox a lot to to
watch John Williams score the movie and
it's just crazy to me the music is so
important because it drives the story it
drives a narrative and it has commentary
on but undertones of emotions when it
comes to each each character I must say
John Williams done very well when Finn
takes off his helmet the music that
plays makes me just go it's pretty darn
cool with all the attention on this huge
movie and even an action figure modeled
after you how has this changed your life
are you able to walk around incognito
yeah I couldn't still do that but I just
feel like I'm doing it on borrowed time
like I feel like my old life is not mine
anymore and I kinda have to give it back
in exchange it for for this new one but
I've enjoyed that this process has been
steady and gradual and and yet it's it's
gonna be crazy when obviously with it
when it's released what was it like
working with JT Abrams
JJ's JJ's fantastic he's a bit too much
Powerman
but we need that to decide but he is it
he's a good director he's any someone
that has a vision he's an actor's
director and and and makes character the
priority and I love a director that can
do that despite visual effects and
and and how crazy and big star was is he
he really fixes on making sure that the
characters work one last question if you
had to describe your experience making
this film in one word what would it be
and why
I would say glorious glorious because I
think for all of the costs specifically
me and Daisy I think being going through
this process has brought out the best in
us the terms of hard work like my in
terms of my personal life being being
able to relate to Finn and relate to
these characters who are in over their
heads but still step up to the cause in
the name of good for me is has been a
consistent reminder of how amazing this
experience has been it's been quite the
right it's been quite the right so you
play pro Tamron a resistance pilot why
is this character a perfect role for you
and how did you make it your own
well I really love the conflict that he
has he's he is someone that comes from a
long line of rebel fighters he believes
in the force he's committed to the
resistance and fighting the first order
he's also has a bit of a problem with
authority a little bit reckless he's got
a he's got a bit of a wisecracking mouth
that gets him into some trouble now and
then and and for me it was a very fun
character play especially the idea of
injecting humor and JJ in in a real
spirit of collaboration I was open to
ideas and even improvising lines here
and there and dialogue and and I think
that's what makes this this this newest
chapter in the in the saga so fresh is
that there's a bit of a messiness and a
wildness to it
and a real sense of humor to the whole
thing is there any part of power that is
like you or that you would like to be
well all of its like me I think every
character that I play really for for me
the job of the actor is an investigation
into the self and the work that the
actor does is is the kind of the fruits
of that investigation so for me it's
about well what would it be like to want
to have something to prove like that to
prove your worth and prove your goodness
and and also to to do that to fly above
everybody else at incredible speeds to
have a mind that can work that fast and
I imagine the feeling of invincibility
in the feeling of immortality and how
that would affect my personality and so
that's kind of where I start from we
hear you come from a family of avid Star
Wars fans how did they react when you
told them you got a part in Star Wars
The Force awakens there was a lot of
near fainting there was a lot of people
turning green and and they just they
they couldn't believe it they were
thrilled and they came to visit me on
set and and JJ even ended up putting my
uncle who was the biggest out of all of
us fan into the film as an extra which
was just the pinnacle moment in his life
what was your reaction when you saw that
the filmmakers actually built an x-wing
for you what impressed you most about
all the practical sets and vehicles
well I when I walked on a set and saw
the real life-sized x-wing that and when
I walked up to it opened up
automatically and I would jump in and I
would close and the lights would fire up
and the sounds the engine could come up
and you have the blue bb-8 behind
they're turning it said it was like a
dream it was hard to imagine and having
all those things on set was was just it
felt authentic it felt really we didn't
feel like we were pretending and of
course also having the original cast
they're having Harrison and Carribean
agency Chewbacca Anthony Daniels you
know it really felt authentic
your character has a new droid bb-8 is
he a scene stealer and how do you think
audiences will like him
I think bb-8 might might steal the whole
movie
it's bebe it's a very special little
droid with its own personality and I
think the thing to remember with Star
Wars is that every time a new movie
comes out along with the film comes some
sort of advancement in technology and
the engineering of bb-8 is a perfect
example of that it's it's like magic the
way that they put that that little droid
together and again that's another
practical set it's a real droid that can
roll around and do do what it does so I
think that's one of the another one of
the rules really special things about
Star Wars how was it working with JJ
Abrams for the first time appreciating
know working with JJ Abrams he infused
everyone with such enthusiasm and such
joy that it was it was really a process
of trusting him completely and and
letting that feeling take over you know
it's really about connecting to that
childhood thing
the Wonder and the excitement and he was
he was just amazing as far as as as
infusing everything with with joy
you